[MUSIC]
The value of communication in
today's world is only increasing.
The way we do it is changing,
be it virtual with webinars or
on our cellphones, but
communication is absolutely critical.
Things are moving faster, there's
more information we have to process,
we are multitasking at
rates never seen before.
The ability to communicate clearly,
confidently, and
in a compelling way is absolutely
critical to business success.
[MUSIC]
When it comes to virtual communication,
especially if you're on video,
there are some things you
can do to really help.
First, make sure you've
got good technology.
Make sure there's a microphone
that picks up your voice.
Make sure you have a camera
that displays things well.
Make sure that the environment
you're speaking in is ready for you.
So that means, make sure there's
nothing distracting behind you.
Make sure you have a lighting,
so that you look decent.
[MUSIC]
Most of the lighting we have in our
workstations is not flattering when you're
on camera.
You want elevated lighting
that's shining on you.
And when it comes to
actually communicating to
people on the other end of your video
conference, look directly at the camera.
The camera is as if you're
looking in their eyes.
Many of us when we interact online,
we look down because our notes are here,
our keyboard's here.
It's as if we're talking to somebody's
shoes if you were having a face-to-face
interaction.
So it's really critical when you're
online, is you look at the camera and
you focus there.
Now you might be asking, how do I
know what to say, I need my notes?
Tape some notes behind your camera.
I actually, in my set up at home,
I went to the hardware store.
I spent $10 for an outdoor light that
a mechanic uses to look under the hood.
I mount that light behind my camera.
I have an old music stand and on that
music stand, I have propped up my notes.
So I'm lit well and I can see my
notes while looking at the camera.
It makes a world of difference in coming
across as somebody who's engaged and
connected.
[MUSIC]
People need to be prepared for
all different types of communication
situations, be it a meeting,
be it a presentation, be it being
an audience member in a presentation.
I encourage everybody to go
into any communication event,
thinking about what are the key
questions I have that I want answers to?
Second, what are the key points or
themes that I want to get across?
And with those themes, come up with
some examples to support them, or
to reinforce what you're
trying to get across.
If you go into any communication situation
with those questions in mind and
those themes in your back pocket,
you will be able to contribute more and
ultimately, take away more
from those situations.
[MUSIC]